Do you have a preference for a sugar substitute? How about monk fruit? You can use monk fruit
You can use
You want to use things like a mute if you're if you're not muted if you can mute yourself. We're getting feedback
You
can use
You can use
Honey, you can use maple syrup
Some people have used the sugar alcohols and I don't I'm not opposed to using the sugar alcohols if
You're using a small amount of it. I mean you're typically not buying that as an additive to make something with
But there may be in a bar or something
Like a protein bar that you're that you're eating. Oh, is this a rhythm called good for you. That's a sugar alcohol
It doesn't spike your glucose. So it's good that way, but they're not necessarily really good for you
So you don't want to be taking sugar alcohols like all the time
But if you eat that protein bar every several days, I don't think it's definitely going to be harmful for you
Some people can have a greater sensitivity to the sugar alcohols and tend to react to them
But that's really mighter amount number in the population. So
They were really big in
Addkins type era when they're addkins bars and all that kind of stuff were really big which which were zero-carb bars
For dietary purposes and things people have been on the addkins
But you know people are eating four or five of those a day. Yes
You're getting way too much sugar alcohols
But if you're eating one or whatever a couple days or something
I don't think that's a problem
But in general, you're more natural sugar substitutes are going to be that
Things that are listed in your binder. I think we have different things like monk food and
And maple syrup and honey and things like that